foreign
is with us in Montgomery Alabama hi
Carrie welcome to the Ramsey Show
having you sure what's up
um so I recently got a divorce while I
left him last summer it was like a
domestic violence situation I had to get
out and I was in nursing school
full-time and so I got out and I got
back on my feet like a lot quicker than
I thought I would um good for you a lot
quicker than he told you you would
oh yeah he said I'd be nothing you know
and you're gonna you're gonna be you're
gonna be the rock star that we all know
you to be I'm proud of you
yeah and um but anyways he kind of
controlled the finances so I did um have
I had a credit card left but I hadn't
been using it I kind of used it to get a
lawyer and to kind of get back on my
feet and so I had about six thousand
dollars left I had like 16 but I've been
paying it off
um and then I got a job I work in like
medical sales now and on my base paid
like 60 and with commission I make on
top of that
um about five to seven every month it
kind of Aries my worst month was like 3
000 but it was when I was getting
started
um but I did buy a house in November
unfortunately when interest rates were
7.25 it's an FHA loan I have 26 000 auto
loan on but a three percent interest
rate I got a really good interest rate
on that and then I have about 18 000 in
student loans so I'm just wondering like
what I should pay off first and then we
just closed on our house we flipped
houses together and I we had to split
the last profit down 25 000 from that
that I just put around the market I got
it I got it like a week ago that'll jump
start your plan yeah good it's making
it's like a 4.5 apy so it's a really
good money market it's a sofa no
um so I'm trying to decide like should I
keep it there what should I pay off
first I really want to get a better home
interest rate but I'm just not sure when
I'll be able to do that you know yeah
well Carrie you're you're doing an
incredible job I mean you absolutely
have
um taken hold of your life I mean you're
doing incredible work wise you're making
great money and yeah you're just in an
incredible spot which I'm really I'm
really happy for you and I mean that's a
courageous
um the whole event isn't a courageous
thing that you just stepped out of and
you said I'm I'm taking life back in my
own hands so I'm just really I'm
impressed by you in that way
um do you have any other money saved
besides this twenty five thousand
dollars that's in a money market account
um not really like I have my banking
account set up for um like 20 I just
stuck it up to 40 of like when I get
paid it just automatically goes to my
savings my money market
um so I was saving like 20 each paycheck
so I have about three thousand then
savings on top of that so maybe twenty
seven thousand okay total that's great
okay so what I would do is I would take
this twenty five thousand dollars and we
teach you to pay off the smallest debt
first so with that 25 000 plus you have
two thousand dollars in your set your
other savings which I would take that
down I would drain it down to a thousand
uh so you really have twenty six
thousand dollars that can be thrown at
this debt which means you can pay off
this credit card
and then you'll be paying off gosh this
this auto loans you only have six
thousand dollars left on your car no by
the end of today no you got twenty six
thousand and eighteen and twenty six on
the car right
yeah she has six thousand dollars in
credit card debt no yes four thousand of
that is like a 24 month interest-free
credit card you got an eighteen thousand
dollar student loan
yes
so you got 18 000 student loan how much
on your credit cards
um six thousand but four thousand of
that is like interest-free I don't care
we're not going to play interest-free
games and interest rates don't matter
you are in debt we need to clean up the
debt okay when you get the debt cleaned
up you're gonna have no payments
anywhere in your life and you're making
money you're going to put this whole
horrible mess in your rear view mirror
and it's just going to be smoke back
there it's gonna be awesome I love it
okay so I would write a check today and
pay off your credit cards and I would
close every one of those credit card
accounts and use only a debit card for
your transactions then I would pay off
the student loan today
okay and then you've only got the car
left at 26 000 right
yes okay
people people here talking about the
student loan forgiveness do you think
that's ever going to happen or
no
okay and you know what even if it even
if it does you borrowed the money you
owe it
yes sir okay and you make good money now
you're gonna be making a hundred
thousand dollars this year aren't you
yes sir yeah so pay off your 26 000
student loan
okay who cares yeah and the house I
bought is a fixer-upper so should I just
wait on fixing up the house yep okay yep
let's get the debts cleaned up because
when you don't have any payments but the
house payment you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year do you feel that
freedom already when I just said that
mm-hmm wow
you got no payments but a house payment
you can fix that house up pretty quick
yeah and no more debt
no more debt you don't need any banks
telling you what to do you got rid of a
jerk that used to tell you what to do we
don't need anybody else telling you what
to do you are amazing go get it done
girl
yeah and when should I refinance my
house since I just bought it when you're
able to get a lower interest rate
all right as soon as you call Churchill
Mortgage and find out what you've got to
do is your credit damaged by this mess
is that the problem
get off a lot of it
it's
um it was like a 650 but now it's back
up above a 700. when did you do that but
before before after you got the seven
and a quarter
um I did that a couple weeks ago when I
first I got like 32 000 and I paid most
of it off with that does that make sense
and then I was making chunks I was doing
like a thousand dollars payments on the
credit card yeah go ahead and get rid of
this debt all this debt and when you get
rid of all this debt you're gonna see
that card that score jump up again and
right when it does that if you can get
down around a six percent that'll give
you a one and a quarter savings that'll
make it worth refinancing and call
Churchill Mortgage and get that if you
can get it down to six percent or lower
it's going to be worth refinancing
and should I do a 15 year or 30 years I
always a 15 year
and Hey listen you're asking a bazillion
different questions about all of the
different things because now you're in
control of your life again and I want we
want to help you with this recovery this
bounce back that you're doing and give
you the confidence on the money piece to
do everything I want you to go through
Financial Peace University because we
want to be a little part of your amazing
story and so you hang on we're going to
have Austin pick up we're going to pay
for you to go through this class it's
online you can do it
and you're is you know when you get all
these answers these questions are all
swimming around your head and you're
going to go through this class and go oh
now I know exactly what to do your
confidence is even going to soar more
and you're probably going to make more
than 100 then you'll probably make 100
and a quarter and with that care you're
going to get every dollar plus as well
and so honestly too the the amount of
control you're gonna feel of just
budgeting when that paycheck hits
knowing exactly where it's going and
once this debt's paid off because even
at the end of today I'm like you could
have just your car loan left at 24 000
and knock it out so you can actually
start to see your goals and where your
money's going and being really
intentional with it and there's
something empowering too about that and
again especially from what you've walked
through the last year and a half to be
able to have full control over that
income where your money doesn't even
have you like you truly have it you are
the one controlling it there's something
in that too and just that simple
budgeting app I'm telling you that's
going to give you so much freedom and so
much confidence so we're excited for you
Carrie by the way for those of you out
there that think you have a friend or a
relative that is a victim of uh domestic
violence
married to a jerk who thinks his wife's
a punching bag
let me tell you a real symptom the data
shows this and we know this from 30
years of working in these situations if
the guy is one thousand percent in
control of the money and will not let
his wife make a single decision of any
kind with the money there's a high
correlation between that behavior and
domestic violence
because if he can control the money he
thinks he can control her and this this
whole domestic violence thing is about
control
and so if you see a guy who's doing that
to his wife he's probably beating her
that's what I'm saying not a hundred
percent but there's a high correlation
to that